oh
hallo
bundesverteidigungsministerium lamprecht
die er an der sitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses
teilnimmt wird angekündigt die
bundesregierung prüfe weitere
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine was
ist darüber schon bekannt geworden
das ist in der tat ein thema was die
parlamentarier hier mit der
bundesverteidigungsministerium
besprechen seit 17 uhr sitzt der
verteidigungsausschuss erneut zusammen
wieder eine besondere sitzung logisch in
solch bewegten zeiten und in der tat
stellen sich viele die frage was kann
denn die bundeswehr überhaupt noch an
waffen liefern und das zweite brisante
thema sind diese 100 milliarden das
sondervermögen was ja auch im
grundgesetz verankert werden soll da
sagt dann die cdu/csu wir sind dafür die
bundeswehr mit diesem geld auszustatten
wir wollen aber mit sprechen wie das
geld ausgegeben wird schließlich braucht
man uns auch bei dieser
grundgesetzänderung es gibt bei den
ampel fraktionen das ist kein geheimnis
durchaus da kritische töne was diese 100
milliarden angeht aber die
verteidigungsministerin hat heute morgen
in einem interview gesagt es geht dabei
nicht um aufrüstung sondern ausrüstung
und das ist tatsächlich ein kleiner aber
feiner unterschied die bundeswehr
jahrzehntelang unterfinanziert muss in
dieser lage in die lage versetzt werden
ihren auftrag zu erfüllen der nämlich
auch die bündnisfähigkeit allein
beschließt und deswegen braucht man
neues material so die
verteidigungsministerin da geht es jetzt
auch darum hier im ausschuss und vor der
sitzung haben sich einige
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
jeweiligen fraktionen geäußert nicht
alle fraktionen werden sie sehen die
linke die sich in den letzten tagen sehr
zurückhält hat hier keinen sprecher
gestellt aber fangen wir mal an mit
rüdiger lucassen das ist der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der afd
es ist gut dass die bundesregierung gut
einer woche nach ankündigung
dieses sondervermögens 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr jetzt detailliert
durch die ministerin hierzu auskunft
erteilt das ist ja nun schon mal eine
besonderheit wir als fdp fraktion
möchten betonen dass wir die ausrüstung
der bundeswehr auch in diesem umfang
schon seit jahren jahrzehnten für
erforderlich halten es wird also das
nachgeholt was lange versäumt worden ist
und
auch wichtig dass es sich hier um
ausrüstung handelt und nicht um
aufrüstung und dass es sich auch aus
unserer sicht nicht in unmittelbarem
zusammenhang zu sehen ist mit dem krieg
in der ukraine
denn bevor die erforderlichen mittel
sowohl am material als auch am personal
in der bundeswehr wirksam werden gehen
vergehen 15 bis 15 jahre also ein
notwendiger aufbau eine notwendige
ausrüstung der bundeswehr um dem
grundgesetzlichen auftrag zur landes-
und bündnisverteidigung
einsatzfähig endlich gerecht werden zu
können wir haben letzte vor einer woche
gesehen dass wir ein sonderprogramm
auflegen ein sondervermögen damit die
bundeswehr
ihre investitionsstau abbau damit wir
diese bundeswehr ins 21 jahrhundert
bringen denn sie hat jetzt eine aufgabe
in dieser sicherheitsarchitektur und
diese aufgabe müssen wir auch wahrnehmen
das zweite thema ist jetzt die situation
in der ukraine wie verhalten sich die
ukrainischen streitkräfte gegen die
angriffe des regimes putin damit werden
wir uns jetzt auseinandersetzungen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir heute
auch außerhalb einer sitzungswoche
wieder zusammenkommen dieser krieg ist
kein krieg der low die ukraine angeht
ganz europa wurde angegriffen von
wladimir putin
viel leisten gerade als deutsche
gesellschaft enorm viel in der aufnahme
von geflüchteten
aber auch in der betreuung und es ist
richtig dass wir heute hier als
verteidigungsausschuss zusammenkommen
und auf unsere pflicht tun und zweiter
unterrichten lassen über den hergang
aber auch darüber was die
bundesregierung noch tun kann um die
ukrainische bevölkerung bevölkerung in
dieser schwierigen lage weiter zu
unterstützen
die unruhe an der grünen basis wenn ich
lese dass es ein brief gibt von grünen
aus der eifel zb
die einfach sagen das ist aufrüstung ist
wollen wir alles nicht ja die grünen aus
der eifel schreiben häufiger mal briefe
und wir nehmen das auch als partei und
auch als fraktion sehr ernst was es da
für bauchschmerzen an der basis gibt ich
habe jetzt in den vergangenen zehn tagen
einige veranstaltungen gemacht mit
verschiedenen gruppen und mein gefühl
und meine rückmeldung die ich bekomme
ist dass es eine sehr breit getragen ist
das ein neuer kurs von der
bundesrepublik jetzt ausgeht und sehr
viel verständnis dafür gibt das heißt
aber nicht dass wir nicht mehr genau
hingucken was passiert sondern es heißt
einfach nur dass wir in einer
gemeinsamen realität sind und da bin ich
auch sehr froh drüber wir haben jetzt
seit über einer woche keine
tatsächlich aufklärung gehabt der
bundesregierung über die aktuelle
situation der ukraine außerdem
interessiert uns natürlich heute auch
die das vor sonntag vor einer woche
verkündete 100 milliarden paket wie sich
das die regierung genauer vorstellt der
bundeskanzler hat ja im plenum hier
einen guten punkt gemacht und gesagt wir
müssen jetzt tatsächlich endlich in die
bundeswehr investieren 100 milliarden
sollen dafür aufgewendet werden seit
diesem sonntag vor einer woche hören wir
immer mehr dass sich diese dinge auch
verbessern wir wollen jetzt ganz genau
wissen werden diese 100 milliarden auch
tatsächlich für die bundeswehr und für
die sicherheit deutschlands für die
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands
verwendet herr söder hat heute gesagt
die union sei nicht einfach der
mehrheitsbeschaffer für herrn scholz in
der frage ich glaube friedrich merz hat
das vor zwei tagen anders ausgedrückt
hat gesagt wir wollen mit beraten wie
diese 100 milliarden angelegt werden ist
ihnen irgendein fall bekannt wo die
opposition bestimmt hat was mit dem geld
passiert was regierung ausgibt naja es
war immer so dass wenn eine mehrheit
erforderlich ist dass diejenigen die
diese mehrheit beschaffen sollen auch
ein wörtchen mitzureden haben angesichts
dessen dass wir hier über eine mögliche
änderung des grundgesetzes reden ist
eine mehrheit mit der union notwendig
und insofern werden wir dann auch
mitreden
also die cdu/csu wird gebraucht die
parlamentarier fragen in diesen minuten
acht details sind diese 100 milliarden
sondervermögen sollen bereits an diesem
mittwoch vom kabinett verabschiedet
werden das hat der bundesfinanzminister
zumindest so gesagt und ihnen ist
vielleicht aufgefallen neben dem linken
verteidigen sprecher war auch der der
spd nicht dabei der herr hellmich aber
die er brauchte vielleicht nichts zu
sagen denn wenn das hier in zwei stunden
zu ende gehen wird dann wird die
bundesverteidigungsministerium sich hier
vor den kameras noch einmal äußern und
damit zurück zu thomas bade der vielen
dank geht ja auch in von verlor
natürlich hat sich nicht nur der
verteidigungsausschuss heute mit der
ukraine beschäftigt sondern das haben
auch die parteien sich in deutschland zu
wort gemeldet übrigens nicht alle aber
einige vertreterinnen und vertreter der
parteien haben wir jetzt schon die